brandenburg sei auch du trittst
verbrannten besser auch verbrennen du
bist doch
ich muss für nordrhein westfalen sein
warum weil ich da fixe summe liegt in
nordrhein-westfalen hannah und aber du
magst auch brandenburg gibt es doch
natürlich bram mag ich brandenburg weil
auch trolle youtuber sind ja sie ist
weiß ich doch sind ja alle aus meiner
höhe
aber wer tritt ein für nordrhein
westfalen an
eintritt für nordrhein-westfalen als
jupiter jupiter jones die sind so gut
auf meyer gelangen sind alle so gut ja
und was denkst du dann ich fahre gar
nicht hin oder
ganz ehrlich dabei ist alles dabei ist
alles hier ist alles ich freue mich
dass nicht du meinst du hast tierischen
fieber wie ist das dann vor so was ich
hab's ja vorhin noch mal erwähnt ja ich
drehe durch ich kann jetzt schon nicht
mehr schlafen wirklich ist wirklich so
ich schwöre ich schwöre ich bin so ich
bin ein nervenkrieg ich übe ganz ganz
viel und probe und probe und ich bin
immer noch so nervös wie ist das du hast
das album fertig du hast es aufgenommen
und dann muss man das ja so fertig gegen
das man es auch auf der bühne performen
kann ist das noch mal ein riesenschritt
das ein riesiger riesenschritt ja weil
live ist ja alles komplett anders als im
studio im studio kann man immer noch mal
und noch mal aufnehmen und noch mal und
noch mal und live ist live ist live der
ist draußen und wenn der ton nicht sitzt
hat dass jeder mitbekommen ok und du
bist aber oder wann gibt es situationen
wo du denkst oh verdammt jetzt könnte
ich mich verhauen oder oder vasco was am
meisten angst ich glaub ich hab immer am
meisten angst davor gehabt mal hin zu
fallen das ist mir bis jetzt auch noch
nicht passiert
ich weiß nicht ob mich das aus dem
konzept bringen könnte aber ich denke
schon also zumindest zumindest wenn ich
beim micro dabei verlieren würde wenn
nicht wenn ich würde ich irgendwie so
noch weiter sinkt aber wenn ich da liege
um ein mikro ist um die zehn mitarbeiter
der musikhalle pantomimisch darstellen
denn wird schwierig das heißt das ist
aber jedem fall ist suboptimal
hinzufliegen es sieht ja einfach nicht
gut aus sieht nicht gut aus
aber sagen wir mal die band verkackt
denn wert schon wieder gar nicht so
schlecht denn sind trotzdem wieder alle
lampen auf mich aber
hast du denn so eine wilde performance
dass das passieren kann nicht wirklich
ich trete ja mit wie konntest du nur an
mit meiner über ballade ja jeder kann so
viel passieren da stehe ich glaube ich
werde vielleicht setze ich auch ich
vielleicht liege ich auch wer weiß das
schon oder hast du vielleicht angst weil
der dass er emotional ziemlich nahe geht
auch im video sieht man es dass du da
wirklich aus der musik heraus anfängst
sollen zu weinen sage ich mal hast du
angst dass so was passiert und die
vielleicht ich stimme wegbleibt oder
angst davor habe ich nicht also wenn
wenn das gefühl da ist und das was raus
muss muss raus was keine miete zahlt hat
immer gesagt nicht aber dass mir denn
das sind wir den knoten im heads up und
dann nicht mehr singen kann wobei auch
das jetzt auch nicht so schlimm wäre
wenn es letzten endes ist musikgefühl
und wenn das gefühl rüber kommt dann hat
doch alles gepasst wie auch immer nicht
auf jeden fall bis jetzt verbrennen
ich werde es rausfinden ob du für
brannenburg angerufen hat ich bin raus
ich strikt auf jeden fall die daumen und
die daumen drückt auch das ist leider
ich bin für mich sehr und wir sind die
bundesvision song contest partner für
doré für das bundesland brandenburg
genommen und wir wünschen so reden
wünschen wir viel glück und erfolg für
das voting für die ganze veranstaltung
auch fleißig für brandenburg an und
damit wir dieses mal logisch dem titel
zu holen wischen sie denn die vielen
lieben dank ich gebe mein bestes und
hause alle rum